this is one of nigeria's government-run
oil refineries in the city of port
harcourt
but most of its operation has been shut
down to upgrade equipment
and facility the government plans to
hand over these money-losing ventures to
investors to run
after decades of mismanagement
africa's biggest oil producer has turned
from self-sufficiency in refined
petroleum products
in the 1970s and 80s to now a net
importer
of the products its four plans continue
to operate well below capacity
and sometimes shut down for months
officials say
that has to start what we have done
different now is to make sure that we
know what we are doing we know who will
do it
and we go back to the original econo
refinery builder
such a way that you know we make no
mistakes about the delivery of that
project
and that is well on course finance is on
ground for one of them
we are working with our partners to make
sure that we have alternate financing
for the total touring families
there's a new agency to complete the
commercialization process
nigeria has been hit by lower oil prices
and a weakened global demand
the government desperate to show up its
revenue base
sees the refineries as a way out of an
expensive fuel import regime
subsidized at more than two billion
dollars a year
nigeria's refineries are about to face
their toughest competition yet
africa's biggest refinery owned by the
continent's richest man aliko dangote
will soon start production
in nigeria it has the capacity to refine
650
000 bottles of oil a day compared to the
combined capacity
of 445 000 in government-owned
facilities
all industries also say between july and
september last year
the country imported more than 5 billion
liters of refined products
a subsidy program that allowed those
connected to politicians to steal
hundreds of millions of dollars
annually has caused the government huge
losses in the past
it scrapped the subsidy three years ago
but
still the losses continue to mount there
we have a line of sight with what this
will be achieved
when this will be delivered and
ultimately we can do nigeria will become
the hub of petroleum product in the west
african
region as a matter of fact we're
expecting
a reverse law of product from from west
africa to other regions of the world
some nigerians say they are cautiously
optimistic
if these national assets are revamped
and properly run in spite of the age of
the technologies that
that produced them over 50 years ago
there are still refineries of that age
around the world that are still fully
functional
so i think they can be rigid to a point
where
they will still come back to their
functionality but in such a way that the
the government of nigeria the peoples of
nigeria still have
their stake in the refineries
officials insist this time it will be
different but nigerians who saw hundreds
of millions of dollars lost through the
subsidy program say
they'll wait to see how and when the
government delivers
on its promise al-jazeera
abuja